lockdowns weren't just a bummer thanks
to them our brats are dumber
and now post covered we shall face the
wrath with screwed up kids who can't
read or do math
the department of education or duh
publish thank you
thank you
publish the report i'll take that
published a report showing just how
awful the coveted lockdowns were on
children's learning
here's a chart the study looked at
nine-year-old perverts
i don't know if i can go through with
this now and found that from 2020 when
the pandemic started to now reading
scores saw the steepest decline in
decades the scores are so low that
parents mistook them for soccer
[Laughter]
soccer sucks
math scores had their first decline in
history they must have over sampled
girls
he's back
it's terrible i don't i wouldn't stand
for that and the declines hit all
regions of the country in almost all
demographics the only positive the kids
mentioned it in the report won't be able
to read it
so there is a happy ending one official
said it's some of the worst drops in
scores in 50 years so we're talking
about going all the way back to the
1970s the dark ages when we worried
about inflation gas prices and ted
kennedy's driving
he killed a girl
remember how dumb we were as kids i put
eight forks in outlets before i realized
i was electrocuting myself
i did
eight and remember that kid down the
block who tried to jump a swimming pool
on his bike or the one that shot a
bottle rocket from his butt
these were not high iq specimens
i didn't think we could get dumber but
thanks to lockdowns your kids are now as
dumb as me when i was a brat
and i only wore a mask when i was
snatching underwear from clotheslines
but hopefully
nobody else did that come on how did you
reach
i had a step ladder oh there you go but
hopefully we can get these children
[Applause]
maybe we can help those children who
miss out on all on the critical
education helping them catch up
otherwise imagine what they'll grow up
to be like
okay brayden can you tell me what color
this is
um
[Music]
red
correct great
now what is this
i
i
i don't know what i'm looking at
uh
you know what let's try another one
what shape is this a pizza which is in
the shape of pizza
try
hey
that's correct you know what brayden you
just passed the first grade buddy oh
great because i gotta get back to my job
at the nuclear power plant i'm the
safety supervisor and we're running a
test at two o'clock two o'clock
it's three
laura
um what hap what would happen if we were
actually wrong and all these kids turned
out better like if we like what if i'm
just trying to see the silver lining but
maybe spending more time with their
parents and less time with their evil
teachers i just want to get letters but
uh
could actually help them i'm just the
devil's advocating well i think it has
helped because they were home with their
parents and parents actually saw what
was truly going on in the schools
because of kovid they were home they saw
critical race theory they saw that
instead of actually learning you know
math and reading and science they were
focused on pronouns and not hurting
other people's feelings and they were
not preparing our kids for the future
it is absolutely terrible that america
has found itself in this position i
think the future of our country is the
most important thing and guess who is so
excited about this it's china because
china is number one in education and i
can tell you they are looking right at
us and they're saying here's another
reason that we are going to soon try and
usurp america as the superpower of the
world they've done it many other ways
they're now looking i'm sure at our
education so the answer is no
no
no tyrus you have children
i am curious to know whether these these
fat this study reflects your experience
do you have you noticed decline among
your kids or is it
no but
and again i'm going to be the bad guy
here uh you always you know everyone
wants to go at the schools and the
teachers and
first world problems but it's it's
parenting we're not parenting good
enough uh
our forefathers whether they were free
or not free had to deal with
famine disease the occasional bear
running through your house wars
and they were able to educate and become
important people
my mother worked
90 hours a week raising two boys we were
stuck at the dinner table doing our
school work
if if the average parent who is
complaining about their kids reading
level and math level
looks at their phone and sees how much
time they spend on the internet and
social media and how much time they
spend with their kids reading writing
and arithmetic i think they'd be shocked
at the time so we can't wait especially
with this administration there's they're
not going to fix it the only one who can
fix it is us we have to take
responsibility and we have to maybe not
watch the 10
seasons on netflix maybe we miss out on
the season premiere or something because
our asses are on the kitchen table
working with our kids because it's up to
us so i don't care what the other
schools are doing i i get off work i'm
stuck on facetime doing math and stuff
and one real quick one thing that
bothers me a lot of times i'll hear
parents say well they changed the math
and it doesn't this is one that i did in
school you don't have the ability to
relearn something you don't you can't
your ass can't instead of buying
something on amazon buy a damn book on
math so it goes back to the parents we
got to be better parents wow
i know
you don't sound like
if i ever have kids i'm just going to
have you parent him i'm just
i don't know but if i don't think i want
to eat off your kitchen table it seems
like there's a lot of ass on your table
that's so mean
uh you you have you have grown children
i have two children yeah yes that's hard
to believe yeah because you seem so
young i know thank you what do you uh
do you think this is a huge problem yeah
i absolutely do uh and you know it goes
down to the fact that the united states
was almost the only
certainly the only industrialized
country that actually shut down schools
particularly k through 12 but also
college my younger son
is in college and he lost a year and a
half of education i mean you know you
get something back but it's it was
ridiculous and it was for absolutely
nothing there was no reason to shut down
schools and whatever we see here i mean
i i agree with you like you know it
ultimately it's all parenting but the
fact of the matter is is like if these
kids that you know nine years old are
dumber now they're going to be dumber at
12 and at 18 et cetera this is going
through the system and we need to
recognize that and make sure it doesn't
happen again you know uh and moved to
china and moved to china lydia you have
uh you have like seven kids yep yes
started young yeah very good i'm a young
88 don't don't you think we're under
valuing dumb children i mean it could
what if dumb children are just happier
and get do more work around the house if
ignorance is bliss why aren't there more
happy people no there you go oh wow
you're like a fortune cookie
it's good to be good at something
i can't believe though we didn't see
this one coming i mean i babysit kids
and yeah and the kids say baby wait how
old are you no
you don't have a real job
we're friends oh my friends you know
it's
i'm a millennial you gotta have a side
hustle i gotcha no no for you know for
friends okay you're making me question
my identity uh no no but i mean they
can't sit and watch a tv show yeah for
30 minutes without checking their
devices and their ipads and their all
the things that they have
and it doesn't take einstein to figure
out that you can open another tab when
you're sitting on zoom school or that
you can upload a video of yourself
smiling and nodding and put that as your
zoom backdrop and be in the other room
playing video games so i don't i can't
believe that we're like finally now like
maybe zoom school wasn't a good idea two
and a half years later yeah and as laura
mentioned china which had the most
draconian covered protocols those kids
were back in person spring 2020. yeah
yeah one of my kids wrote buffering on
the bottom and put a white piece of
paper over the door
genius but the whooping was thorough all
right up next how did they miscalculate
and alert to evacuate hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else